hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome to the classrooms oh that
made my voice sound a lot more epic than
it really was hi welcome to the
classrooms how are you doing one second
okay pick a tape I don't even know what
that means intro experience the story
and learn the basics
basics of what I don't know what I'm
doing well I guess that's why I was
explaining the basics
okay it's recording
hello
would you say
now how do you work this thing
oh
oh can I need my flashlight
okay
probably should have charged the battery
on this thing oh
maybe I should just shut up and let the
game explain itself because it seems to
know what it's doing
take the van key
all right whoa
was good
okay
unlock the van
all right
move open the back door okay the Codex
off you maybe
I'ma find you maybe meme I'm gonna find
you meme
if there's a meme to be found I'm gonna
find it
that way double click to use mystery
deepens on missing children school
closed early for summer students gone
missing during school hours
okay interesting
I need to break the glass hope nobody
hears this what glass I don't see any
glass it's a chain link fence what are
you stupid
what am I stupid well I'm inside now
I'm magic
oh no one hears this bomb
gotta find the breaker room
uh
God damn that flashlight does nothing
okay breaker room
why did I break into here anyway
uh all right then
hmm
ah
electricity must mean breaker
that's the squeakiest door I've ever
heard
what's wrong with you
or whatever
almost out of batteries again which is
weird terrible flashlight
ah
just in time
am I okay I'm not okay
I'm okay
oh
cool
[Music]
ah battery good
while everything's physically
interactable which is kind of cool
it's not usually what I see in games
like this
um
I'm still a little unclear as to what my
objective is
I'm exploring this but I don't know why
can you tell me why
wait where am I
that's a good point where am I
oh hi
that's horrifying yep confirmed
horrifying
also confirmed running a bit like a
chug-a-lug
really whoa
ah you know from what I know about
clocks that's not quite right
hello where did you go
where did you go
why would you go anywhere
closer than they appear
quality
Safety First Walk do not run
you can't tell me what to do I'm an
adult I'm not in school anymore
I don't need to play by your rules
[Music]
uh
you are horrifying
no you
had a funny feeling also where's the
kitchen this isn't supposed to just be a
place here there's supposed to be a door
that goes into a kitchen
they got to cook the food somewhere
if cooking the food is what they
actually do
wait a minute
okay I thought the the thing in the top
right was listening to my voice and I
was like well I'm not prepared for you
to actually know what I'm saying
that's not okay uh
I get it
in that I don't get it none of this
makes sense it's not supposed to be
cohesive anyway I found a codex entry
though
November 3rd 1978 they woke us up early
today even 5 a.m when the alarms rang
this time it was different went up and
my eyes it wasn't our oh usual character
I thought the note was cutting up usual
caretaker shaking us awaken ripping our
covers off but a row of armed guards
armed with machine guns standing quietly
near the door the rest of the day was a
blur we rushed to throw our clothes on
and we're guided towards gymnasium but I
already know what Horrors they had in
store for us
I don't why don't you ride more and
smaller so that I can see it
good great this is good
great
good
oh
okay
well I'm outside
[Applause]
oh
what
the fork
oh my God
where where am I
is this just an endless void of Darkness
oh my God please do not kill me while I
read this I finally have the will to
write something again I have no clue
what time it is I think it's the ninth
but even trying to keep track I can't
tell what time it ever is all the clocks
are different and none of the light is
real I haven't slept in days but I'm not
tired at all I still haven't found any
food but I haven't been hungry since
they sent us through the same with
drinking something is very wrong here
keep changing this isn't the same as the
real world this place it never was made
for us to see
right
what is glowing over here
just shout it man
God you know you could shut up
over here in the light
two points
well I'll never get it I will never I'll
never get it
oh my God if that thing comes bouncing
back I will literally kill
again
freak
thought I saw something in the corner
there
and if I didn't don't make me look like
a fool elixian put something there and
creep everyone out but actually don't
just make it think that you're listening
to me and no one will know if there's
something there or not but definitely
or don't
it'll be our little secret
wow so is this randomly generated
no you know I don't know why I'm
surprised doors are doing that that's
how doors actually work uh usually so I
guess I shouldn't be too shocked
I'm not late for the meeting
hey what's up
oh shaky
anyway
how we doing here
good good good
oh my flashlight's happening
it's good to have the lights kick on I
guess
I'm unsure
of anything
holy God
all right okay you're just gonna operate
in front of me
it's gonna appear out of no ways
and just leave me in the loach
fun
under the bench or are you talking about
the key that I just got
whoa it better not be something in there
I swear let me
just so I can see and stuff like this
but I don't need to have it on all the
time because the power is technically on
ah
well that uh that woke me up good
um you gonna do that again because I'll
be ready for it this time I promise you
that I promise you that
foreign
well I'm finally in hell now I knew this
was coming for a while now after the
incident we knew they were going to send
us in next they gave us all the
documents that have instructions on what
to retrieve from here but we didn't even
have time to read them or prepare before
we were rushed in I have no food or
water and the only thing they gave me
for production is a flashlight and a
compass the one thing they did tell us
was that the documents to grab if I want
to get out of here alive I'm going to
need to remember these Lambda 407 Alpha
903 Tau one two three
so am I in some kind of an SCP Zone
oh this is some kind of a back room
situation
the classrooms I guess I should should
get
I don't like this one
I don't like this desk that's not right
[Music]
I'd like to think I have my crush
what are you doing
[Music]
oh my God
oh you were deadly oh you were deadly oh
you could kill me
oh you bat me with your baby ends what
were you thinking doing that you can't
do that
where am I am I that's illegal
oh it is different
oh my God
oh no
today is a great day to grasp the void
I disagree but you know when is my
opinion ever mattered when I go into
these things can I use excuse myself
well I feel
fit as a fiddle
oh wow that is dark and horrifying
yeah don't know why I turned on the
lights I don't know why I bothered
well this isn't right I think that's the
the nature of this game you walk in a
place and you go like nah it's not right
what's the deal with that this is where
I came in before
What's your deal
nope it's different it just looks like
the place that I was before because it
was slightly familiar but now it's not
ah good great
outside speaker talk table whisper no
voices no voices what do you mean by
Novo why you gotta say it like that why
you gotta say no voices I gotta be all
why couldn't you just be like silence or
something like that why you gotta say no
voices that's weird why would you say
that
of course there's no voices
but that doesn't inherently mean that
there's no sound if you say it like that
is weird
probably just a normal ass
School poster and I'm freaking out about
nothing
am I supposed to remember these symbols
because I'm not gonna
I refuse hey look at that
found something
Arc Anonymous anomalous retrieval and
containment well well well would you
look at that 004 ah malicious entity
anomaly 4 is a malicious entity that can
be found in the alpha and Lambda
superstructures
004 is a sentient ceramic doll that can
move only under certain conditions these
conditions are no sentient being as
observing 004 and something else when
either of these above conditions or Matt
The Entity will aggressively pursue and
eliminate any adult human The Entity
fines The Entity will focus on disabling
the target's sense of sight by gouging
so I'm guessing the eyes but it could be
anything as well as the above mentioned
properties item 004 has ability to set
fire The Entity is also very physically
capable being able to overpower adult
males and
no one knows a rhinoceros any sighting
him died in 004 must be reported
immediately if the ND is encountered
evacuation of the areas required in the
event of a retrieval and containment
assignment no less than three operatives
are required all of which will require
higher powered flashlights and headlamps
two operatives must maintain constant
visual contact with the entity while the
remaining operative focuses on
containment well that would have been
good to know a little bit ago you could
have just said SCP-173 and I would have
been like ah yeah Never Gonna Take My
Eyes Off of that thank goodness I don't
blink in this game
[Music]
what is wrong with you this damn door
thinks that it's gonna be all squonky
door
interesting I wonder what this is for
what do you mean what do you mean by the
pitter patter of footsteps
well I hate that
some of the nominus down there
[Music]
shut up I was right when I said it isn't
safe here that much was explained in the
documents everything else is far more
vague there are documents that give very
vague instructions of what to do but
often what not to do like to avoid dark
rooms with vents in them and to hide in
lockers if we hear anything strange
there are some other documents of what
seems to be specific things to avoid but
most of the descriptions are covered in
Black Ink and it's possible to decipher
what it's supposed to be at least I know
why they gave me a compass now it
doesn't actually Point North it points
towards where the entrance back into the
school is at least it should it was also
mentioned in the paper that there are
multiple checkpoints they placed around
the space that was in use before the
incident the incident huh
what incident
I hear you I'm assuming the baby's
behind that door and I'm gonna go down
this way exit
you almost made me choke
I don't like that
I'm out of here
[Music]
oh
okay well this doesn't bode well because
there's a baby over here
[Music]
where's that baby
where you at baby oh I see you
yeah yeah yeah okay if I can keep you
how quick are you how quick okay not
that quick oh not that quick oh just
toddler fast which is slow I'm honest
shut up
go away
okay there's nothing over here you shut
up
I wonder if that key fits this oh I bet
it does
hurry
oh my God nope don't even think about it
idiot
I win because I'm an adult with a big
Smart Bro
brain
I have a big brain
a fully developed brain great
someone was having fun with mid-journey
oh boy
good bathroom
nothing like a liminal bathroom
stop you have nothing better to do
baby
what is this supposed to be it's almost
completely blacked out
oh good yeah this is helpful hey RC uh
malicious are you kidding me when I
asked for a level three clearance of
this document you could have just said
no this is useless to us whatever this
is 686 our malicious entities that
appear docile however human contact
shift in mood and appearance as the
entity will change shape the entity will
be then become hostile to the human and
attempt to deceive potential prey
physical appearance resistance
yeah you know I gotta agree with this
one this one doesn't make any sense
what's the point of this what's up point
was the point of redacting like it
doesn't make much sense
what would be the point
I don't see why any of the highlighted
areas were classified information
sensitive government secrets yeah okay
yeah all right whatever
shut up
you back here
run hide Escape I don't like that
I mean I like those things the escaping
part definitely but why
that baby
Hazard what is that 608 is a
non-corporeal entity that manifests in
locations devoid of Light Within any
location of the superstructure currently
discovered when a viewing after
manifestation entity 608 will appear to
have glowing white eyes and a large
mouth full of teeth since 608 is
non-corporeal it is not affected by
solid objects or walls in any area
devoid of light however for unknown
reasons it can still interact with
physical objects and inflict wounds onto
entities will appear in any of various
devoid of Lights 608 will vanish if
trapped in an area was subsequently lit
up but over time will disable said
lights and remanifest if a sighting
event entity 608 occurs avoid any
contact with the entity if spotted by
The Entity make sure to stay around the
lit areas and to avoid any areas dim or
devoid of light as entity 608 has been
known to pursue prey relentlessly until
there is no dwelling area for the void
of Light Within Luke millimeters that
would be useful information so stay in
the light is what I'm gathering
replace my battery are you over here
I'll try door number two
hello how are you doing
so good to see you shut up
shut up
loser says stop
I said stop God damn it I'm the loser
new sound new fear
what is this what is this big bathroom
I'll get you trapped in the bathroom
here
you'll never get out
oh
stupid
you're dumb
get trapped idiot
I probably need to go in that bathroom
well
too late for that ER whatever shut up
well that's just red okay uh malicious
typically not be visible
catch the human subject will proceed to
it
large amounts of electrical current hide
in an area devoid of artificial light
due to the nature of the superstructure
may be difficult to find yeah I don't
think that anything's about going to
have artif not I'm pretty sure it's all
that
thing
what
was that
what was that
uh Child come here
where are you
I can't see
wow
look at you dummy going right for me
you're bowling over everything stupid no
stop
no you stop
all right let's see what's in this
bathroom
peekaboo
peekaboo peekaboo
oh that might be important
but I don't know
peekaboo
what
don't laugh at me
oh that's not right
that's also weird
oh God the world's most difficult toilet
lid fine
[Music]
this is strange
I'm confused
where am I going what is that I don't
have a key was I supposed to find a key
because I didn't get one yeah I know I I
was saying that if you'd let me finish
but at least I know where this is I
guess where my album where am I
this is bizarre at the very least I do
have a path to get up here that's kind
of a straight shot I mean it's the
curliest shot possible but you know
it'll go there let me check these last
holes anyway just in case
okay hi handsome
I don't like the buzzing does that means
[Music]
oh my God what's wrong with you don't do
that
stop doing that stop stop cease desist
desist desist
oh hey a key wow this should open the
elevator it should shouldn't it
desist cease cease immediately
I gotta go
I heard that what did I hear I don't
know I'm going for it
I don't know what I heard and I don't
know what any of that is and I don't
care I'm not dealing with it and I'm
never dealing with it you can't make me
deal with it I'm not going to deal with
it and you can't make none deal with
nothing
I'm free
for all eternity
that's pretty impressive the random
generation that it's got here
all righty then
good to know I made it to the third I
hate it I'd like to go back
uh
what is that
I want to go home
oh my God I know it was dark
oh my God
are you serious oh did he hear it oh no
no I'm pooping please don't kill me
oh please don't kill me
oh I'm pooping
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Applause]
oh please
you got toilets on your ceiling there
as long as I'm quiet it won't come kill
me
what or
stupid
um I don't know if it's a good thing
that I haven't run into it yet but
I feel good
so you know there's that
I don't know what to do
I just
truly don't appreciate the Galloping
foreign
[Applause]
won't do anything for you maybe running
like a madman
I'm just gonna run like a madman
am I running right into it good
oh wow I'm running right into it aren't
I oh
shoot
oh no
why would we do this
[Music]
uh oh that's ripples look bad
oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy
is it going away I think it's going away
what if I oh I know what I'll do I know
what I'll do
yeah you know
you know what are you doing today
how do you know how do you know
[Applause]
[Music]
does this save I'm just gonna see if it
saves
I'm gonna leave it there and I might
come back to this let me know down in
the comments if you want me to try to
finish this I think there are four tapes
I did not do too good at that juncture
but maybe I'll do better next time gotta
be a way to get around him and it's all
about using the sounds but apparently he
kind of notices me through the walls and
once he bows onto you there's really
nothing you can do but let me know thank
you and as always I will see you in the
next video bye-bye
[Music]
thank you